so there i am naked still holding the
hedge trimmers when the chauffeur walks
in and i say
guess you caught me red-handed because
of the blood yeah because of the blood
see you get it
the bullet went through your friend's
shoulder he should be fine although
he does keep asking me if we do the
face-off surgery here
and what'd you tell him that we don't
right
she's hiding something obviously yeah
okay adrian there's very little evidence
to go on so we should take a look at
your pi case files
don't have any keep everything right up
here in the old steel
where am i what is this bed and his
memory's resetting all right adrian
someone's trying to kill you uh-huh you
have a memory disorder that makes sense
like in the movie momentum i haven't
seen that
it's like finding dory oh now i know
exactly what's going on thank you
charles
okay let's get you dressing back to the
precinct where it's safe okay
oh adrian the back of your gowns open
don't peek at my tushy i'm not
wait since when is your back covered in
tattoos it's not
otherwise i couldn't get buried in a
jewish cemetery are you jewish not yet
ooh
i should ask that nurse if they've got a
moil on staff wait maybe you've been
getting tattoos to help you remember
things like the guy in memento again
haven't seen it no the tattoos
could be clues that you're leaving for
yourself here we'll step out you get
undressed and write down everything
you see and you're fully naked hey oh
all right well i guess we're looking at
them together
this is just a list of modifications on
a signature salad from panera
okay this one says buy toilet paper in a
truly
gigantic font i hate to think of the
horrific event that led to a reminder of
this size uh this says your bank account
number is four three two two one one
three seven eight
then just under that someone saw this
and stole your money oh
yeah this just says don't trust your d
okay
well that's good advice my d does get me
in a lot of trouble are you sure that's
what the d
stands for oh it's for sure my dong it
could tell some stories costa rica in 98
nom nom it's coming up oh no there's a
bomb in my chest
save yourself no no no no it's just your
little watch okay means it's time for
you to take your pills you keep them in
your right coat pocket oh
okay where's my code it's down in my car
ah i'll go get it you stay here no no
your penis is out
i'll go okay
boy i love that little guy right yeah
nope my phone's right got to grab it
it's amy am just put her on facetime
no come on hey what's going on hey just
checking in
how's it going with charles and how hard
this is for you have you told him
anything
nope we're still all good he has no idea
that we are growing a whopping willow in
your chamber of secrets
well i have to get back to the seminar
also you've ruined sex forever yep i
heard it i don't know i keep doing it i
love you
bye what was all that about oh
i actually really can't tell you uh wait
a minute you're the only person that i
can't tell because your brain's broken
anything i say you'll just forget well i
guess that's true
give it to me amy and i are trying to
have a baby what jake that's wonderful
come on bring it in i'd rather not but
it still feels really nice to talk to
someone about it finally
but i'm gonna be a dad it's so crazy hey
don't mention this around charles
where am i oh perfect
you